look I've got a nine-year-old baby girl
at home I cannot imagine what's that
what that's like for the girl for her
family God forbid something that like
that would happen but let's talk about
that case because why was a 10 year old
girl raped in our community raped in our
state in the first place the thing the
media and Congress and Ryan they talk
about this all the time the thing they
never mentioned is that poor girl was
raped by an illegal alien somebody that
should have never been in this state in
the first place you voted so many times
against border wall funding so many
times for amnesty Tim if you had done
your job she would have never been raped
in the first place do your job on border
security Don't lecture me about opinions
I don't actually have my position would
be that we find a car we find just some
common ground thing and it's hard to do
and we can talk about whether that's 12
weeks I think 15 weeks which is you know
now you're into the third month whatever
it might be